the URL that we built looks good and the
JSON string from the server also looks
good however it still is one long string
let's look at it more carefully to see
what data we should extract from it in
order to make sense of the string that
comes back from the server we can put it
through a JSON format or a JSON pretty
fire if you google for those terms
you'll be able to find a helpful tool
such as this one here we pasted the
result of the web query then it
formatted the output for us showing us
the hierarchy of these elements now
based on the wireframes that you saw for
the sunshine app can you tell us which
of these leaf nodes we care about
extracting even though we will have to
traverse through parent nodes for the
purposes of the quiz on next screen
we're just looking at the leaf nodes
make your selections below on which
attributes we'll need in order to
display the list of forecasts